turn fear on itself
feel fear quite strongly here is the
fuel undoes the fear I grandiose my way
out of fear fear embrace that fear
transcend that fear
hello believe nation my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major challenges and
so to help you on your mission today
we're going to learn how you can
overcome your fears and as always guys
if you're watching the video something
really speaks to you please leave it
down the comments below and put quotes
around it to other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick for yourself
as well enjoy the only way to deal with
fear that I found in my life is a couple
ways one of those ways is to turn it on
itself and ask yourself what am I afraid
of I'm afraid of that I got to be more
afraid of what I'm going to miss out on
Missy on ammunition missing on who I'm
supposed to be missing in other words if
you know you'd get rid of fear than use
fair use fear or uses you it's that
simple
so you got to say ok what's the price if
I just stay doing this what's the price
what I need to really get scared if I
learn all this I don't follow through
that's somebody scared about
and then that fear will get you over
your fear and they'll push you through
turn fear in itself second way you can
do it is use what you've probably heard
me say because I've used it I was 17 in
my little rocking chair test right I'm
gonna I'm gonna sit myself in my rocking
chair I'm 85 years old and looking back
on my life and I say I didn't do this or
I did you're unusually fearless and
willing to go in the face of other
people telling you something that's
crazy and I know a lot of pretty crazy
people you still stand out where does
that come from or how do you think about
making a decision when everyone tells
you this is a crazy idea or where do you
get the internal strength to do that
well I love us all I'd say I actually
think I see if feel fair quite strongly
so thought as though I just have the
absence of fear I've I feel it quite
strongly
there are times when something is
important enough you believe in it
enough that you do it in spite of fear
so speaking of important things like
people shouldn't think I should think
well I feel fear about this and
therefore I shouldn't do it it's normal
to be to feel fair like you'd have to
definitely something mentally wrong you
should feel fair so you just feel it and
let the importance of it drive you to do
it anyway yeah you know actually
something that can be helpful as
fatalism some degree you could just
think it's just accept the probabilities
then that diminishes fear so I'm
starting SpaceX I thought the odds of
success were less than 10% and I just
accepted that actually probably I would
just lose lose everything but that maybe
would make some progress if we could
just move the ball forward even if we
died maybe some other company could pick
up the baton and move and keep moving it
forward so that we're still doing good
yeah say what Tesla Gilad to the clock
company succeeding were extremely low
there's always here and I even put it in
rocky through that you know he's I'm
afraid I'm afraid the fear is what the
fear is the fuel that we use for
overachievement
if I wasn't afraid of time I wouldn't
work as hard and because the fear is I
don't want to sit back into mediocrity I
don't want to just say okay I want to
rest on my loss so I'm here footsteps
all the time and I know that I only have
a certain amount of time and I don't
want to waste it because it's going so
quickly and since rocky has been on one
set in half eight years and I
dolly and I are just overachievers
because we know that there's only a
certain amount of productivity in a day
and we don't waste it I'm a writer I'm
supposed to be behind the scenes and
everybody else is supposed to be in
front of the stuff now she's finally in
front of the camera the famously private
woman talking about her epic struggles
with anxiety and her fear of public
speaking
what physiologically happens when you're
having that Stage four panic attack
there's a little bit of panic breathing
there's a lot of pacing back and forth
and mumbling to myself just like being
invited to every glamorous party in
Hollywood she'd make excuses saying she
was just too busy until one day her
sister provoked her I was sort of going
on and on and on about like all of the
invitations I'd received and my sister
finally sort of cut in and said are you
going to say yes to any of these things
and I remember being very taken aback
and saying no I'm busy I can't and her
sort of looking at me like that's insane
and at some point just saying you never
say yes to anything and those words
really sticking with me because she's
right and so this became a campaign to
say yes to the things that scared you
yes yes the things that freaked me out
and when you started saying yes what
started to happen it's the doing of the
thing that sort of undoes the fear when
you experience moments of self-doubt how
do you approach getting out of that dark
place good question I grandiose my way
out of fear if you can imagine that it's
a good way you know I it's like
literally it's like okay I'm going to do
one of the greatest car chases of all
time and if I don't I'm not as talented
as I thought I was and I will realize
that there is a ceiling to my talent
right now I don't think there is but if
I don't do but if it's not one of the
greatest cartoons of all time then I
failed and I there is a feeling in my
time I'm not as good as I thought I was
and I said that to everybody
and was I scared yeah all right I had
trepidation going all because it's mine
to fail and it was Maya nubium and it's
failing in front of me
- because I'll know if I did it or not
and I'll be like okay you are not as
good as you thought you were and that
got me to Mount Everest it's true every
one point he goes Robert can you imagine
you and me doing this car chase together
how great it's going to be in a mic game
and you're on your own brother are you
going out there me I got five kids I got
100 mile an hour pulls we want to live
the vanishing point dream but he live it
he did all by himself and I'm so proud
is that the difference between because I
see you in your basement like like a
Batman with all machines aha it's really
precise I guess and really what you
could you know what you put and then you
go live yeah what's the difference
and there is a risk the risk you know
and and the risk and I have stage fright
you know and I never confronted the risk
or when I did come from I mean Belgium
you know 2000 year 2000 that was you
have no idea but it took them to get me
to do it no no no no I had a thousand I
had a thousand excuses why not to turn
it I finally I did it and it was
exquisitely horrifying that's the only
way I can felt complex yeah it was very
very very complex and what was really
good was Reiser beginning within like
two seconds
I played just the worst wrong note and I
could either stop and cry or I could
laugh right and it didn't kill me and
nobody else out there
nobody was throwing anything you know it
was fine thank you to the people of
Ghent for not killing me and giving me
the courage and you know and the the
absurdity you know you have to be able
to laugh at yourself and you have to
learn how to laugh at yourself if you
say I'm a fraud they'll figure me out
I'll never be able to do it again
that's an artist start processes you're
an artist you're thinking like that
you're on the right track because they
all feel that so you there's always some
success
I come out even out of your failure the
fact probably your biggest success will
come directly from your failures you
should almost take that Winston
Churchill's quote as my favorite success
is moving from one failure to the next
with great enthusiasm you should be very
enthusiastic about your feelings because
you're going to learn something you're
going to go that way whenever when I was
going that way and you're going to
stumble but you're also going to stumble
upon something that no one ever thought
of so you know you just keep going and
keep going and you're going to fail and
then rise up and fail again and that's
the journey up and down then most of us
that come from just normal backgrounds
we don't see ourselves doing abnormal
things the world is full of people who
were born on 3rd and think they hit a
triple and they've got all this
confidence all this stuff for most of us
it's not that way we don't think we're
wired or programmed to do something
great well I'm telling you that thought
is nothing but a fear nothing but a
doubt it's what holds you in place you
got to work hard on understanding you
have within you the power to change the
power to do something great and those
fears are going to crop up particularly
in the middle of the night when you wake
up and you're scared to death about what
to do they're going to crop up and
they're going to hold you in place quite
often if you trying something different
they crop up in the middle of your
dreams when you're asleep at night those
fears and doubts creep in understand
they're not real they are things in your
head that have been programmed into you
by your past life wrestle with those
fears you'll never conquer them but
control them and go out and live the
life you deserve choose to win control
your thinking and go win big whenever
people reach out to me and say you know
I'm doubting what I'm doing I say well
congratulations you're a human being
that's what it means to be a human I've
I've you doubt what you do it's that
voice inside our head you know it's
innate and all of us we're born with the
imposter syndrome so
you know we don't walk outside of the
cave at dark with the saber-tooth Tiger
it's like there's a voice saying don't
walk outside it's dangerous but we don't
live in that same world anymore but we
still have that inside our head and
that's fine but we need to learn not to
let it control our lives but to embrace
that fear and so I still have it every
single day I mean we talked about my
revenue last month you know I still wake
up and say man like you know should I be
doing it like like should I do this
webinar like is that you know I have
these doubts in these fears and that's
just a reality and I've just learned to
embrace that how what's the first step
to overcoming the fear or transforming
this fear hmm to witness it to be to be
the non-judgmental witness of it to look
at it and say something's got to give
right so so if you're unwilling to look
at your fear head-on and honor it and
and witness I always say if you don't
show up for what stuff it will keep
showing up so looking and saying you
know I witness my resistance and you see
that fear as resistance it's right it's
fear as a resistance to what it is that
you desire and in the absence of
resistance you become a magnet for what
you desire when you let go of that fear
and you transcend that fear that's when
you start to become a super attractor
that's when you start to let what is
truly of essence for you into your life
what is truly of service for you into
your life what is true happiness into
your life and so looking at the fear
witnessing it calling it by its name and
even if you don't have the tools yet
what happens is when you look at the
fear and you're like oh I see this year
I see this resistance I see how it's
blocking my life and I choose to see it
differently that's when you're listening
to an audio like this that's in a book
like yours will fall off the shelf
potala look yeah you know exactly you
open up your consciousness pretty much
you crack open your consciousness to
find solutions rather than find problems
and so when you're not looking at the
fear you're just living in the fear and
you're believing in the problem but when
you witness the fear and you're willing
to see it differently you start living
in the solution thank you guys so much
for watching I love to know what did you
think of this video what clip spoke to
you the most what are you going to take
from this video and immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business
leave it in the comments below I'm
really curious to find out I don't want
to give a quick shout out to Ryan
Sakhalin Ryan thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
here one word and offering to do a
review on it for your blog I really
really really appreciate the support
mate and I hope you enjoy the read so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is
much love I'll see you soon